European finance and economy ministers
will work to close an EU tax loophole at
the next council and Brussels The
ministers want to reach a political
agreement on new rules to ensure that
cross-border groups could not introduce
alone arrangements that might have them
avoid tax on profits at the headquarters
and subsidiaries abroad the aims to stop
these firms from exploiting differences
in national tax systems and potentially
take advantage of double non taxation
the ministers are also set to discuss
the possible introduction of a financial
transaction tax in 11 EU member states
last year the council decided to move
forward with the tax on the basis of an
enhanced cooperation procedure Britain
is challenging the move in the EU stop
court in other items on the agenda The
ministers will discuss an in-depth
review of macroeconomic imbalances in 17
he you states the review conducted by
the European Commission is part of an
annual process aimed at keeping the EU
economy and balance and encouraging
sustainable growth